the benefits of this fungus could be
humongous yeah there's a growing
interest in legalizing magic mushrooms
as people take a second look at its
medicinal benefits it's also popular
with mds who call their patients dude
psychedelic compounds like psilocybin
the one that makes the shrooms so
magical are being studied for their
potential use as antidepressants and
even performance enhancers especially if
your performance is sitting through a
four hour fish concert
at the state level legalization could
happen sooner than you think and why
well the risk of fatal overdose or
addiction is a fraction of that of
alcohol veterans also say psychedelic
therapy helps them manage their anxiety
and ptsd and it could also be effective
for people who work with brian kilmeade
let's stop there
because the next joke isn't that funny
you know um kat uh you have absolutely
no experience with psilocybin and
neither do i
but isn't it important to keep an open
mind
yes
it's obvious how much research there is
that you know it can't help with
depression it can't help with ptsd and
so on and so forth but also
i don't think that matters as much as
the fact that we shouldn't be
criminalizing a decision for what you
want to put in your own body so i think
you should be allowed to do it even if
research just showed that it was kind of
fun
absolutely i don't mind it being used i
don't mind anything being used
recreationally including me
[Laughter]
kt you took magic mushrooms in the green
room
how do you feel right now you're flying
aren't you oh i'm having a terrific time
yes yes
yeah i told you it'd be great
yeah it's gonna last about four hours
no but i mean i'm one of the people who
thinks that we shouldn't legalize drugs
in any way shape or form oh i don't know
but yes with with the veterans that it's
a big issue oh
so i gotta i gotta go to war veterans
yeah
but i mean other people can't raise you
know the suicide rates are people with
ps yeah but there's also overdoses on
illegal drugs there are sky high right
now like a hundred thousand this is
amazing and that's because people can't
measure this stuff effectively and so if
you make it legal or get a prescription
then it's in a dose that is easily
manageable which is what you're seeing
with you know opioids versus fentanyl
fentanyl people are just croaking on
that stuff
so i think that um i understand your
compassion for the veterans because you
are a veteran
i'm not but my family is and my
daughter's still a lieutenant commander
in the reserve this is the second time
you've done this that would happen
yeah i mean i have a civilian equivalent
rank of a three-star general oh wow but
yeah no she's a half veteran yeah
well no
she's happy do the math later uh adam uh
do you have any experience with
psychedelics i've never done mushrooms
but i always said if there was one drug
that i was going to try it it fascinates
me but see i go out in la i go hiking at
joshua tree this national park out there
and that's when people try to pressure
me to do mushrooms they always say they
go you have to go to joshua tree and do
mushrooms joshua tree is beautiful on
mushrooms and i always tell them like
you know what else is beautiful on
mushrooms your garage yes
or the bathroom out of wendy's
everywhere everywhere is beautiful on
mushrooms yeah and also and also you
don't want to go to some place you're
not familiar with
for the first time on something or
or you should just be at a place that
you're comfortable like your home and
i've heard you should be in a good mood
because it'll be good
yeah don't be around people that are
weird you're going to guide me through
it greg yes i will well i'll meet you
after the show
tyrus uh have you ever tried i what are
you laughing at
have you tried oh yeah
oh yeah uh i i still
i one time but whoo
uh me and my boys were hanging out with
playing dominoes or whatever and we sent
a guy out for pizza
and maybe marijuana not sure maybe that
was that's what he came back with a bag
literally he was like jack in the
beanstalk he was supposed to go out and
get food and came home with a bag full
of beans well homie came home with a bag
full of mushrooms and he's like you boil
it you put in the tea and you drink it
and we're like this ain't pizza this
ain't green
so i guess we'll do it yeah and i was
like this is dumb this is so stupid but
we had for some reason in the middle of
our apartment we had this velvet
painting of a river
and i didn't notice it at first but like
as we would walk across the river my
friends would take the shoes off so they
could walk across because they didn't
want to get their shoes wet with the
river going across the living room and
then that's when i realized it and then
one of my friends went to walk and i
grabbed him and i was like you can't
swim homie don't go over there it's not
good
so
it was
it was pretty cool and then right around
one o'clock in the morning i ended up in
my underwear sitting in style waiting
for people to come get me
after that i was done yes i did it once
but i think anything that grows from the
earth
we should always try to find the good
things in it and not ban it absolutely
because even a coca leaf done right is a
good thing it's when it's taken and made
evil and twisted and yes outdoors but
things that grow from the earth we
should really use them for what they're
for yes and if you if you come up with
certain precise measurements everything
everything could be medicinal everything
because i wasn't getting my jordans wet
it wasn't happening
all right i think we solved the world's
problems by the way if if putin got a
psilocybin dose
the world would change actually all
political leaders should do
shrooms hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else